human relationships are a way to
understand the true value of code
who maintains that code and why we trust
them to maintain it while this might
seem strange at first it's not so
different from how we think about
valuing cities infrastructure and other
systems of human complexity
the author jane jacobs offered a similar
approach in our 1961 book the death and
life of great american cities where she
criticized the contemporary 1950s
approach to urban planning
according to jacobs urban planners
treated cities as static objects
considering how they should be developed
only at the time of creation
rather than continuously revising their
plans according to how people use them
the urban ministry practitioner douglas
hall describes this as the cat and the
toaster problem in his book of the same
name
douglas said that churches neighborhoods
cities and cultures are complex and
interrelated living social systems
they're like cats but as he puts it
we've grown accustomed to thinking of
our social context not as living systems
but as
objects we can easily measure and
control like a toaster
but the problem is that we still tend to
think and talk about software as a
static object
taking it out of context it's why we
have this myth that software is zero
marginal costs
ignoring the complex human
interdependencies that are required to
maintain it
we treat software like toasters instead
of cats
you